so the world is going
electric and batteries will do for
electrification what the refrigerator
need for food because batteries will
allow us to move clean energy through
time and through
space we don't have a problem with the
availability of energy on this planet
we have a problem with getting this
energy to where we need it and when we
need it but if we approach battery
manufacturing the wrong way we will end
up repeating mistakes from the past
mistakes that are at the heart of the
climate environmental crisis that we see
today and that's what I'm here to
explain it's all about the way we are
using the Earth's resources so
historically and today uh we have been
mining uh oil from the earth crust with
little concern to the long-term effect
and this example of how we've been
approaching the fossil fuel industry and
how we've been dependent on it h how we
have been extracting oil where it's
economically possible refined it burned
it and it ends up in the
atmosphere that's the perfect
illustration of the fundamental simple
and linear model that we are working
with extract use and
discard when I was a professor in
environmental engineering I used to
teach my students that mistakes are okay
as long as you learn from your mistakes
and as long as you take
action so now when we are evolving when
we are
changing when we're building things from
scratch we should think twice and we
should do it right this time
and what does this mean for
Batteries H there are two things we need
to know about batteries one is they
require enormous amount of energy to
produce and the second is they're made
from minerals minerals that requires
Global mining refining and processes in
long and complex Supply
chains so if we start with energy uh a
battery factor is a very large and
complex operation it requires large
amounts of heat
and electricity to produce it starts
with a chemical plant then follows long
uh coating
machines after that we have cell
assembly which is fine Electronics
equipment that require clean and dry
rooms now in the end of this process
each and every battery cell needs to be
charged and discharge in certain
patterns to gain its properties and if
we put this kind of factory on under a
fossil fuel grid we will end up with a
carbon footprint which is the Benchmark
today which is around 100 kilog of
carbon dioxide per kilowatt hour
produced battery and how much is that
and that is uh if we take it at scale so
2030 years production uh of battery
manufacturing will give the total
footprint about half the size of Germany
now that would be a big
mistake luckily you can slash that
footprint with some 67% that's
2/3 if you put the same operation on the
renewable energy grid which we do in
Northern
Sweden that on the other hand leaves us
with the remaining footprint the last
third coming entirely from everything
that is outside the fact
uh and the lion part from the supply
chain and that leads us to the second
topic we have to talk about which is the
minerals so batteries are made from
minerals that the for example nickel
Cobalt and lithium and the way we
approach this is going to determine how
much we can further slash that carbon
footprint luckily if we put it under
this renewable grid if if we approach it
the right way uh with sustainable Mining
and a lot of
recycling we can significantly reduce
the footprint one ton of lithium battery
grade lithium requires 750 tons of rine
or 250 tons of lithium
ore same with Cobalt if you need one ton
a battery grade Cobalt you have to mine
300 tons of Cobalt Ore so does this give
us a similar situation to the oil
history we had no because the difference
is that when we mine
metals they are elements and if you can
get elements back to their Elemental
form they are just as good as new and
this is the fundamental difference
between the combustion engine history
that we're leaving now and the new
electric vehicle industry because at the
end of the life cycle you can bring the
metals back from the market and you can
use them again and again so what we have
developed at North vaal is a recycling
process where we take uh the batteries
back from the
market we discharge them fully we take
away the aluminum casing we take away
all the
cabling and and then we take out the
cells and the
modules H we take those cells and
modules together with some waste
material we have from the production and
we throw it into a big
Shredder we shop it up we take out the
the foils the copper foil aluminium
foils and
Plastics and then we're left with
something that we call the black mass
and this black mass is a fine black
powder and this fine black powder
consists of everything that we had
coated on the electrodes in the factory
it's the graphite from the anode and
it's the nickel Cobalt manganese and
lithium from the
cathode we take this fine powder the
Black Mass we pass it on into the
hydrometallurgical
process uh hydrometallurgy means
treating metal in liquid and what we do
is that we use different pressure
changes temperature changes
and pH to separate them from one another
we refine them so we get them into the
form that we need for the production
salts for nickel Cobalt and manganese or
hydroxides for
lithium and then we do like this we send
them across site straight into
production so what we have is a circular
battery
economy and this is the fundamental
difference between the combustion engine
industry and what we are building
now we should do this not only for
batteries we should do it for wind
turbines we should do it for solar
panels we should do it for all the new
industries that we need for this
transformation and we're going to thank
you and we're going to have to accept
mining as part of this transition
absolutely Ely but when we are taking
things from the earth crust when we are
borrowing from the future
Generations we have to do it responsibly
and we have to make sure that we can use
these materials over and over and over
again because
fundamentally we can and we should not
only build recycling processes and aort
for the materials when they come to
their end of life we should also be
build accounting and traceability system
so that each car maker can follow up on
Trace how much they can further sash
their footprint by sending the batteries
back at the end of the life and while we
are doing this I'm sure you already
figured this out it's not only
environmentally
beneficial it's also of course
economically profitable because by doing
this the material sustains its value
through the
lifetime and this altogether may sound a
little bit hard it may sound a little
bit complex but if we get this right it
will be rewarding on so many
levels and I can tell you that the Young
Generation of talents of Engineers that
we hire today they understand all this
and they ask nothing less from us
so with that said I just want to say uh
to all of you who listened uh and I also
want to say to all the people who packed
their bags and moved up to the nordics
who are fighting every day to make this
happen thank
you